[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es einen richtig genial und
bürger ich mache einen falafel burger
mit richtig leckerem grillkäse ihr habt
ihr wirklich schon oft nach einem
konzept gefragt heute gibt es eine
abgewandelte variante aber ich kann auch
gerne mal das richtig die original zu
bereiten
ich bereite die bürger heute in
kleinformat so das heißt wird so eine
art vorspeise oder beilage zum grillen
ich mache nämlich keine burger brötchen
dazu sondern nutzt einfach die verlasse
drückte flach macht das ganze als so wir
als bürger brötchen der satz und der
grill these ist dann der fleischsaft
also ist das ganze auch vegetarisch und
dann richtig coole hatten aber wie
gesagt könnt ihr das ganze auch gerne
als kurze wörter zu bereiten was macht
ihr denn so wie ihr möchtet
ich mache jetzt erstmal die verlassene
masse und zeigt euch die zutaten für die
falafel verwende ich 600 gramm
kichererbsen aus der dose 1 bund
petersilie ein bisschen koriander eine
zwiebel sechs knoblauchzehen jeweils
zwei teelöffel kreuzkümmel und salz und
jeweils eigenen teelöffel pfeffer und
backpulver bei den verlassenen arbeite
ich jetzt mit dem fleischwolf aber ihr
könnt zum beispiel auch einen mixer
nehmen
aber ihr braucht auf jeden fall ein
gerät womit ihr einfach die kichererbsen
schön weich bekommt den fleischwolf gibt
sie auch als handkurbel gerät damit geht
es auch oder wie gesagt einfach mit mixa
jetzt schalte ich einfach
zwischen maschine an ich geb dir oben
erstmal in paktika erbsen rein dann gebe
ich die kräuter hinterher
verkleinern damit sie auch durchgehen
[Musik]
ein eigenes mag ich keinen koriander
aber in der falafel schmeckt exporte man
da wirkt das muss zu viel nehmen
zum verbund etwa also deutlich weniger
als die petersilie aus passt echt super
rotation knoblauchzehen und die zwiebel
gilt auch für oben rein
das will muss selber habe
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich diese masse hier heute
wirklich leid und laster mit dem
kompletten gewürzen verrühren
wo könnte aber auch ganz gut mit den
händen verkneten oder mit dem teig
sauber zum beispiel kreuz ist ganz ganz
wichtig dass heute gibt doch verlassen
so die typischen geschmack und rühren so
sieht die masse jetzt aus ich habe es
jetzt um gefüllt damit diese besser
sehen könnt und ich habe einfach so etwa
ein halbes esslöffel mehl dazu gegeben
weil sie einfach noch ziemlich feucht
war
es kommt einfach immer darauf an wie
lange er die kichererbsen abtropfen
lassen ob ihr die petersilie und den
koriander nach dem waschen noch
schleudert oder nicht also wenn es
wirklich zu weich ist und ihr merkt
zwischen den fingern aus lässt sich
nicht so gut formen dann gebt ihr ein
bisschen mehr dazu jetzt könnt ihr den
einst portionierer nehmen ich nehme
jetzt die mittlere größe
ihr könnt aber auch die große größe
nehmen aber ich mache jetzt kleine
burger mini burger und formen jetzt hier
erst zu einer kugel so war es jetzt auch
eine verlassen sondern ganz normal die
man frittiert und dann folglich noch
platt damit es wirklich aussieht wie so
ein bürger partie
[Musik]
warum gibt es hier noch fertig und
stellt sie dann kurz zur seite und
wettern in der zwischenzeit schon mal
italien soße machen
das ist eine sesampaste und daraus wird
die leckere soße zubereitet später noch
auf die bürger darauf kommt für die
sauce nämlich 175 sesampaste also dahin
175 vom wasser zitronensaft eine
knoblauchzehe habe ich noch die gewürze
salz pfeffer kreuzkümmel und ein
bisschen blattpetersilie die sesampaste
die bekommt ihr übrigens in gut
sortierten supermärkten gibt es auch
mittlerweile glaube ich in
drogeriemärkten und auch einen
türkischen supermarkt da heißt total hin
jetzt nehme ich da ein bisschen wasser
dazu damit auch wirklich eine schöne so
serviert zitronensaft wir können das
jetzt entweder in mixa zubereiten oder
einfach mit einem stabmixer so mache ich
das jetzt das ist übrigens auch eine
richtig leckere salatsauce wir kommen
jetzt einfach alle zutaten rein und
knoblauchzehe natürlich natürlich
knoblauch petersilie salz pfeffer und
kreuzkümmel jetzt einfach schön pürieren
die sind schön dickflüssig am tag hin
bei der saison passt für mich übrigens
aufpassen und zwar wenn ihr dann glas
holt oder so ein gefäß dann setzt sich
das gerne ab also unten ist es immer
ganz fest oben schwimmt die fettschicht
und ihr müsst es immer erst noch schön
durchrühren und dann verwenden ansonsten
ist es wirklich ganz ganz dickflüssig
ich habe ein bisschen wasser übrig
gelassen ich glaube es zieht jetzt auch
noch ein bisschen wenn ich merke es wird
doch zu dickflüssig dann für dich das
wasser noch dazu wie jetzt im moment
finde ich so ganz gut
jetzt stelle ich noch die joghurt soße
her da machen wir einen richtig leckeren
mit joghurt für den mini u boot verwende
ich den gashahn joghurt davon 400 gramm
und wird sie ihnen dann mit salz pfeffer
chili und münster ein joghurt ist nicht
viel zu tun da gebe ich jetzt einfach
die gewürze dazu und höhere intern
cremig
ich werde jetzt gleich die falafel
burger frittieren ihr könnt aber auch im
backofen zubereiten
ich habe das hier mal an dem großen
stück ausprobiert und zwar könnt ihr die
bei ober unterhitze über 190 grad backen
bisher an der unterseite braun sind das
dauert etwa 10 bis 15 minuten und dann
einmal umdrehen damit auch die oberseite
brown wird und dann noch mal einfach so
drei bis vier minuten
so sind sie natürlich fettarme bleiben
aber auch trockenen
ich werde sie gleich frittiert und bei
160 grad und kann jetzt aber auch in der
zwischenzeit schon mal den grill und
fanden käse zu bereiten da nehme ich
jetzt hat die geschmacksrichtungen
kräuter und kann den jetzt erstmal zu
schneiden
schneiden jetzt einfach ein bisschen
quadratisch zu und die übrigen kleine
stücke die kriege ich das so noch mit
[Musik]
ein käse braten schön kross an
die falafel berger kommen jetzt
vorsichtig ins heiße fett
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier alle komponenten
fertig und kann jetzt die bürger
zusammenstellen also zuerst nämlich
jetzt hier die verlasse
dafür übergebe ich einen text joghurt
damit den käse
[Musik]
selbst noch ein bisschen tomaten und
trocken kleingeschnitten einfach in 2
der wölfe noch obendrauf
[Musik]
märz am besten einem zahnstocher
fixieren damit sie nicht rutschen und
dann können darüber noch die italiens
installieren
schönes fingerfood was man aber nicht
mit den fingern essen sollten sondern
mit messern gab murat kann jetzt kommen
die bürger mini parteien ist es
vegetarisch ja okay das ist immer so ein
thema wenn man nachher werden wenn man
wenn wir zu besuch leute hat die ziegen
und vegetarischer fragt man sich was
gerecht würde
ja ich bin auch kein vegetarier habe ich
es halt nicht so oft ja nein ich
eigentlich zu 80% vegetarisch und die
sorgen und wir sollten eher weniger
fleisch essen
da bleibt mehr für mich übrig ich sage
ich gar schon gedacht ist cool die
profis ganz probier am besten genau mit
messer und gabel
was gibt's da auf den teller rüber und
was ich muss herausfinden kann schon
okay glück ist er nicht sofort den mag
ich hab's halt nicht geschafft und wie
es verlassen
ja komm mal geschehen guck mal wie schön
grün die verlage erinnern noch ist
wollte ich sagen die vier stationen hast
du machen so ist schon gar nicht
reformieren ja ein anreiz noch mache das
einen bürgerverein ist das areal
vegetarischer burger will junghans also
das habe ich auch zu anfang gesagt man
kann daraus einen richtigen bürger
machen oder eben dieser mini bürgertum
hingefahren bin im bürgerhaus das ding
wir die total einschlagen ja richtig
einschlagen
mcdonald's wenn ihr seht so sieht man
digitale bürger aus also richtig genial
hier
okay ich habe zehn monate
ich kann sie der nächste mal gern wieso
in so einem manchmal ist ja auch
verlassen in seinem luftschiff also ein
ewf geist nicht aber auch mit dem brot
und dann mit dem kaeser dass wir bürger
von euch im bürgerladen hat ohne spaß
macht das gut gemacht das macht das
wirklich
die würden leute werden gestützt haben
also ich finds so richtig cool vor allem
als vorspeise zum beispiel zu einem
grillbuffet ihr könnt es gerne
nachmachen schaut gerne das rezept an
auf sallys - blog.de ich würde
jedenfalls noch chili ergänzen aber ich
habs jetzt raus gelassen weil die
meisten hier nicht so ganz scharf essen
was bedeutet der nacht werde ich meine
hand zum glück guckt euch das ding an
macht es als alaska als einfacher bürger
richtig genial haben wir ehrlich super
freut mich also viel spaß beim
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
hallo und korean dass man im verlauf
aber es schmeckt echt gut
[Musik]